what happens if it's a completely  different language it depends on the  language  so for something like chinese or the  kanji in japanese and a lot of people  won't agree with me on this in the  language learning space but generally  i would say it's a waste of time to  learn that initially  you want to be able to phonetically  represent the language now this doesn't  mean  learning how to write chinese or  japanese is a waste of time it just  means that  you want to follow a similar pattern to  how chinese and japanese  children learn the language they all  learned the spoken language  first and then they learned the written  language and i  got around to learning the hansa the  written form of chinese  after i finally reached a conversational  level in mandarin  and it was so much easier now that's for  those  very different languages for a language  like russian or  many other languages that have phonetic  scripts to them  it's really not that bad to learn it  quickly